well guys it's finally happened we
thought Star Wars Eclipse was going to
be canceled but that is not the case as
we have an exclusive report here which
I'm going to read to you guys now so
inside a game and sources have revealed
that Star Wars Eclipse developed by
Quantic dream is targeted attentive 2026
release date but it could be delayed
further sources once again restated
Quantic stream struggle power and star
following allegations of workplace
issues including sexual harassment
Crunch and toxic work culture in fact
one whistleblower who brought these
allegations to light is still in legal
battles with Quantic dream which is
expected to finalize later this year
it's understood that due to the scope of
Star Wars eclipse and alleged issues
with higher end staff the game could be
delayed further for its 2026 Target
because of such day targets Star Wars
eclipse is likely the most far out Star
Wars game that has been announced so far
there are six announced Star Wars games
in development that are yet to release
Star Wars eclipse is described as a new
action event multiple characters of
branching narrative games set in the
high Republic era of the iconic Star
Wars Galaxy and here is every Star Wars
game in development now a lot of people
were saying this game is canceled and
they were never set a light of day for
this game but according to this this is
not happening and it just may be a bit
delayed as a struggling to hire staff to
work on this game but nevertheless we
will eventually see this game if this is
in 2026 all of it is a bit later like
2027 or even 2028 whatever the release
date is we will be seeing this game so
it is happening guys this game is still
happening and from that trailer that we
saw it looks pretty damn cool so I'm
excited that this game is still coming
out and I'm curious to see what the scam
will look like and when we'll release so
let me know your guys thoughts in the
comment section below and if you're new
to the channel and you did enjoy this
video please consider subscribing and
liking the video thanks for watching
guys